[Music]
here we go again
july is here and so are the games ps
plus subscribers can download
all the following games are available
from tuesday july the 6th
so if you've pressed subscribe to be
kept up to date with all future ps plus
and free games coming to playstation
let's do this on the ps5 this month is a
plague tale
innocence a third person adventure
stealth outing set
during the black plague lovely we pilot
two orphans through 14th century france
as the streets are filled with rabid
rats capable of eating a man in mere
seconds
over the course of the game you'll learn
how to control those rats using fire and
light
and a host of other items and abilities
including a sling the main focus is
avoiding battle and playing as stealthy
as possible as enemies can one tap our
character
diversions and openings to hit the
perfect shot are what the game push for
although there are boss fights too which
are more like a david and goliath
situation
a plague tale innocence released to
about 8 out of 10 reviews back in 2019
and on july 6th the game's ps5 update
drops and you'll get it
day and date on ps plus oh one last
thing the final boss fight
is brilliant i won't spoil it but no
it's very good
will you try a plague's tale innocence
i'd love to know your thoughts
over to the ps4 now and wwe 2k
battlegrounds
in a break from the usual simulation
style affair 2k
instead made this a game which you can
feed a wrestler to a crocodile
the depth of other wrestling titles has
been pushed aside for a more pick up and
play feel
with only a handful of moves per
character the solo campaign mode
sees the comic book approach of telling
your story from backstreet wrestler
to wrestlemania headliner with feuds and
fights along the way
the most fun is playing this with
friends picking up guitars and wailing
on each other
characters can be unlocked using in-game
currency which is built up during
playtime or you can buy them with real
money if you so wish
wwe 2k battlegrounds won't last you a
long time as there is not much depth at
all but it is a totally over the top and
amusing grab fest all the same
to keep this in focus the average review
score is 4 out of 10.
yes don't expect much from this game and
it might make you happy
and finally black ops 4 is here once
again the call of duty game
which ditched a traditional single
player mode in favor of more online
multiplayer action
which is a good idea because black ops 4
takes place before black ops 3 but after
two
confusing much as always the gun play is
undeniably fantastic
and this was the one which introduced
the new ballistic system
and should we ever forget black ops 4
brought us the first version of warzone
good old blackout mode battle royale
rejoice
the famous zombie mode is here too with
over 100 variations on the zombie horde
with a new modern day call of duty
looking unlikely in 2021
this could be perfect timing to replay
blops i can't call it blops it's black
ops 4.
do people really call it blops so those
are our games for the month of july
2021. what do you reckon
be sure to give your review in the
pinned comment below because i'm keeping
track of all your opinions
i'm adam you're awesome see ya
[Music]